-Coming from Newark
and being a mayor,
where you´re actually connected,
I think,
you know, to a place more
than senators can be sometimes,
´cause they´re in and out.
You were just in --
You were in Newark.
You were living
and breathing in Newark.
And gun control --
You just co-sponsored a bill
to ban bump stocks.
But I think your experience
in Newark is that handguns
are still the biggest issue
when it comes to gun control.
What are the steps,
as someone who actually,
you know, lived in a city
where that was an issue,
that you think
we could take as a nation?
-Well, I very proudly
still live in Newark,
and I live in the Central Ward
of the city.
It´s a low-income community.
And we deal with
these realities.
In fact, as trag--
What happened in Las Vegas --
my mom lives in Vegas --
It´s a terrible tragedy,
and it should grieve us all.
But in addition to that,
though in the aggregate,
every single day in America,
we have a mass shooting,
in the aggregate.
And communities like mine,
you know,
right around the time
that we had this shooting,
horrific shooting --
In fact one of
our congresspeople
got seriously wounded, there
was a shooting on my block,
literally across the street
from where I live.
So this is something
we Americans --
Millions of us
deal every single day
with high levels of violence.
And what I found out
in Newark is
it´s actually not
law-abiding citizens
that are doing these shootings.
They are criminals
who so easily in this climate
can easily
get their hands on guns.
And so when you have these
massive loopholes in the law
that Democrats and Republicans,
gun owners and non-gun owners,
all think --
In fact, over 80% of gun owners
think it´s crazy
that we live in a nation
where a suspected terrorist
can go to a gun show and fill up
a trunk full of weapons
by exploiting
the terrorist loophole.
The overwhelming majority
of Americans think
we should do something about it.
Congress has not acted,
and this is outrageous.
And we should rightfully
point out the NRA.
But please understand
that we in America,
we forget the power that we have
to make change.
You know,
the Civil Rights movement --
We didn´t get
civil-rights legislation
because Strom Thurmond
sat there and said,
"Okay, yeah.
I´m going to do that.
I´m going to give
equal rights to folks."
No, it was Americans
demanding it, fighting for it,
getting up every single day.
The opposite of justice
is not injustice.
It´s indifference.
It´s inaction.
And we as Americans
who believe this passionately
have to get engaged,
have to start pressuring,
have to start pushing,
have to start fighting,
or else we´re gonna --
I fear we´re going to see this
continuing on a daily basis --
dozens and dozens of Americans
punctuated by these
mass shootings.
It´s gonna continue to happen
till we stop it from happening
and pass reasonable gun-safety
legislation in our country.
-Well, best of luck.
I´m pulling for you there.
Thanks you so much
for being here.